why'd you open a breach I didn't
somebody's coming through to back
wells
your help goodbye hey guys Jesse your
speed suit Wow procore hey we're looking
for a meadow with super-strength
my daughter Jessie quick guys this
thing's coming down riding Jessie this
Tuesday at 8/7 central on the CW hey
youtubers is Charlie so we finally got
Jessie quake so this is the episode 3
trailer let's break it down it's gonna
be all kinds of trouble in the best
possible way so Jessie quick finally a
speedster I'm so happy like I loved it
when Violet beam came on last season I'm
so happy they're not wasting any time
going there and for everybody wondering
what her costumes gonna look like it's
gonna be red with yellow highlights so
you can see it kind of in this box here
you can just see the red top with like
the gold lining here so it's gonna be a
variation on the comic book costume but
I think it'll look really steampunky in
the style of earth too you know like
everything on earth-2 looks really
old-timey Art Deco compared to earth one
design style so it's gonna flow from
Earth to design language but also be
kind of a deep cut from the comics so
just really excited about that the
interesting thing though is that you
know wall-e and the trailers like oh my
god you're speedster but it doesn't seem
like he's a speedster so the big
question is is like are they
flip-flopping a lot throughout the
season like there was a big thing during
Savatage run where like all the other
speedsters besides Wally West who was
the main speedster at the time Barry
Allen hadn't come back in the comics yet
so wally west was like the main version
of the flash wearing the red costume so
a bunch of the other speedsters besides
Wally started losing their powers
because of what's avatar was trying to
do so there was this big FOMO thing
where it's like you know you go from
being super special to not being special
anymore and you're all depressed so I'm
wondering what they're gonna do with
Wally because it seems like he doesn't
know that he had powers during
flashpoint because at the end of last
week's episode they all made that
collective decision we don't want to
know what happened in the previous
timeline so putting two and two together
you just have to imagine that you know
they wouldn't make that Wally West
costume and spent all that money on that
if
they weren't gonna let him wear it
throughout the rest of the season so
maybe they'll have dr. alchemy tempt
Wally with his powers maybe he's having
the same type of dreams that the rival
was having so Jesse quit coming on the
scene and having all this fun with Barry
is probably only gonna exacerbate that
so you have that going on with Wally but
then you just have like the sheer fun in
the thrill of Jesse quick being a
speedster like it looks like she's
having the time of her life in Harrison
wells just cannot figure out what to do
so she's been on earth to saving people
using her powers just you know trying to
be the flash of that earth doing the
things that you would expect somebody
who became a speedster to do just trying
to be a hero but here some Wells isn't
having any of it so they'll be like this
nice family arc with Jessie and Harrison
wells this season him just learning to
deal with the fact that she's going to
be a speedster she's gonna be in harm's
way but then you have magenta who is the
rogue like the new rogue of the episode
so she actually debut during Teen Titans
during Wally's era as the flash in the
comics she and Wally grew up together
they were friends but then she got
powers and things did not go so well for
her so you kind of have this parallel
arc with magenta and Jessie quick you
kind of see what they're doing here
we're by new young girl speedster gets
powers learns to deal with it in a
positive way another young girl gets
powers as a metahuman things do not go
so well she becomes a rogue and goes
down the darker path so as you see in
the trailer most of her powers involve
magnetism like it seems like telekinesis
but it's basically magnetism so that's
how she's able to lift that big ship
liner at the end like that's like the
big action set piece of the episode like
early on they say oh you know we're
looking for a metahuman who has super
strength but that's only because
someone's throwing cars around like we
see here but she is this tiny looking
adorable little girl Sophia magnetism
fleeing stuff around you get to the big
action set piece it's gonna be a big
training moment for Jessie and the cool
thing about Jessie quick is that she's
gonna be in the next couple of episodes
I don't know exactly how many but at
least the next two episodes because as
you would expect she looks really
confident in herself she I think last
season they said she had at least a
couple advanced degrees so she's
basically smarter than anybody else
on the show right now like she's
supposed to be smarter than Harrison
wells and she has superpowers now so she
probably feels invincible and that's
usually what happens right before
someone gets the rug yanked out from
under them so during the mirror master
episode which is episode 4 there's gonna
be that ocean moment where her
overconfidence bites her in the ass but
not really sure what that is just the
description of the episode says it's
something like pretty terrible happens
because it's Jesse's overconfidence but
those of you that are worried about them
introducing too many new speedsters just
remember that Jessie quick is from Earth
too so what'll happen is is eventually
she'll just go back to earth-2 and be
the flash they're like Jay Garrick is a
speedster but he's not on earth 1 so
he's not in every episode so he's out
there when they want to use him for an
episode so like hey you know Jay Garrick
comes and helps Barry for a week so the
multiverse is a really good tool for
controlling the number of speedsters on
screen at any given moment I think
they've done a pretty good job with the
way they set that up like it explains
why they're not all standing around
talking to each other every single week
but either way new flash episode on
Tuesday so be sure to subscribe to get
it there's a new round of the DC
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video next week's episode of
arrow 2 is gonna be a lot of fun because
Cody Rhodes is guest starring and if you
didn't see it during SummerSlam last
year he in Steven Amell threw down in
the ring it was when he was still
Stardust in the WWE so I might do a
trailer video for that so he's basically
going to beat the out of Oliver in
the episode it's gonna be like
SummerSlam round 2 payback is a
but there are a couple other videos that
I want to do first so that arrow video
might post later this weekend but we
have new Walking Dead there's a whole
bunch of stuff so I'll try to remind
everyone what the schedule is as I post
new videos so next video will probably
be new Game of Thrones just because
there's been a whole bunch of stuff
happening on the season 7 set well you
guys wait for that to post you guys can
click here to learn all about Aquaman
and Mira and the Justice League movie
and you can click here for my dr.
alchemy Theory video from last week's
episode so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys